let's talk about health care health care
is one of the most important two to
three issues affecting America at large
and whatever issue you care about I've
talked about this before if you care
about reproductive rights if you care
about education if you care about
foreign policy what are the most
important overarching issues that will
impact your ability to be active in your
community number one how politics are
financed because that is so much of how
we get the positions we get from our
elected officials how we learn about
issues is influenced through media which
directly relates to money in politics so
money in politics impacts just about
every political issue that might be
important to you and health care impact
it as well because if you're not healthy
if you're if you think about Maslow's
hierarchy of needs pad to become self
actualized which is at the top of the
pyramid of those needs you need basic
physical security you can't be wondering
where your next meal is coming from and
you need to know that you're going to be
able to get health care when you need it
so health care much like money in
politics do you agree Pat it informs any
issue that is important to you yeah it's
the the one that trumps all other issues
you could say Trump's for lack of a
better term so what's going on with the
American Health Care Act well Senate
Republicans have been drafting the new
version of the American Health Care Act
basically in secret I told you last
month that the bill was passed by the
house it hadn't even been analyzed by
the Congressional Budget Office
Republicans threw a party at the White
House to celebrate eventually the CBO
analyzed it it was an absolute and total
disaster tens of millions of people
would lose health care senators said
we're going to clean it up we're going
to transform it into something that
everybody's going to like better and now
it is in the Senate Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell says he wants to
put it before a vote before the Senate
recesses their last day is June 30th
next Friday before their fourth of July
we get week recess there are 13
Republican senators currently working on
it really is their staffs that are
working on it they're not showing it to
anyone it's been total secrecy they
haven't had any public hearings about it
they haven't even shown it to others
integers Republican senator from
Tennessee bob Corker said to the New
York Times quote the process is better
if you do it in public and that people
get by and along the way and understand
what's going on obviously that's not the
route that is being taken Rand Paul
Republican senator from Kentucky
commented saying quote I think it's
being written uh by someone somewhere
but I'm not aware of who or where if you
get a copy of it will you send me a copy
Bernie Sanders Chuck Schumer two other
Democratic senators sent this sort of
trolling satirical letter listing 31
different physical places where they
could potentially hold a hearing on this
listen Pat I guess health care is just
one of those unimportant minutia issues
that doesn't really need to be discussed
publicly I mean it's health care after
all it only affects every single person
in the country and one-fifth of our
economy I mean to defend Rand Paul a
little bit here I don't think he would
be one of those Republican senators who
would vote in favor of this bill yeah
not because you know he's this
progressive champion criticizing it from
the left as we are but because he's
criticizing it from the right maybe I I
mean it's what we don't know what's in
it we just don't know what's in it and
we've now heard that tomorrow afternoon
Republicans are going to release the
bill to their fellow Republicans in
other words the 13 Republicans working
on it will make it available to
everybody and they want to vote on it in
a week you need time to read through it
you need time to do amendments you need
time to debate those amendments but
let's go back to what Republicans say
about this strategy Mike Pence in 2010
when he was a congressman tweeted about
this saying quote it's simply wrong for
legislation that will affect 100% of the
American people to be negotiated behind
closed doors of course then he was
talking about Obamacare not the affor
the American Health Care Act a tweet
from Senator John McCain in 2009
Democrats about to pass health care bill
that no one's read where is the
transparency what a disgrace
current Health and Human Services
Secretary Tom Price also back in 2010
when he was a congressman saying quote
with Democrats discussing health care
and secret there
sacrificing the trust of the American
people the entire Senate as I mentioned
will get to see the bill tomorrow the
political complexity now is starting to
become a factor Pat campaigning did
Donald Trump basically his entire
campaign on repeal and replace Obamacare
the reality is you kind of can't repeal
it and replace it with something more
right-wing and not either increase the
cost or decrease access because after
all Obamacare is right-wing I might I
don't know if I'm spilling a secret pad
Obamacare is right-wing saying we are
going to mandate that people buy
for-profit insurance plans and we will
allow the for-profit insurance companies
to submit plans to this system where
people can select a plan that's a
right-wing idea and so you can't move
healthcare to the right and improve it
the way Donald Trump says you can
Obamacare sure did start out as a
right-wing plan but now you have this
house health care plan which is even
worse only 21% of Americans approve of
it and Donald Trump even called it mean
so I think you know the Senate plan will
be a lot more moderate and Trump gave it
a rousing endorsement saying that he
thinks it will be generous kind and with
heart but he also said it needs to be
okay yet generous kind and with heart
right yeah with heart what does that
even really mean I guess he means that
it won't ISM it won't directly lead to
the deaths of tons of people but it will
indirectly do so I guess that's
considered having hard I don't know
funny note about this Bloomberg ass
Republican Senator John McCain if he had
seen the bill and he said quote no nor
have I met any American that has I'm
sure the Russians have been able to hack
in and gotten most of it
I don't know that Russia even really
needs to hack it right I wouldn't be
totally shocked to learn that Trump's
PACs the Kremlin a copy
he talks a really big game as far as his
credentials and blah blah blah blah blah
and then he just spills just about
anything that's going on to to Russians
but John McCain in spite of I guess I
would say despite being tough on Trump
with the Russia stuff he still votes
with Trump 90% of the time he spent that
entire James Comey hearing talking about
Hillary's emails I agree with with what
John McCain is saying here but his
action
are not really being tough on Trump and
apparently John McCain is on snapchat
who knew I mean you say let's read the
Twitter profile picture
that's a snap chat icon filter oh I'd
that's jesting yeah John Boyle got them
all to me I didn't know about it